we have a topic simple topic after
everything that happened last week in
the NFL the most impactful additions not
just free agents can be trades as well
but it has to be an addition don't do
anything like well somebody franchise
tag someone no no or resize someone no
it's got to be an addition it's got to
be someone new those are the ground
rules I've got the trivia question if
you get it right you get the first pick
if you get it wrong I do all right Tom
Brady played 20 seasons in New England
with him gone who is now the longest
tenured member of the Patriots roster at
12 seasons oh I think that's gonna be a
1 Matthew Slater you are correct sir
well done we don't have the horn today
we're working on a skeleton crew at the
studio but you you go first
well I wonder who I'm gonna pick here
I'm just not sure I mean of course I
don't think this is the best player in
free agency but you want to talk about
impact Tom Brady is the most impactful
new addition to any team I mean hey he's
the goat he's six rings he's Tom Brady
he's an American icon at this moment at
this point of his career or his life and
not only is the impactful into like man
we've never talked about the tamponade
Tampa Bay Buccaneers so much in the
offseason and it's only two weeks into
an off season we've already hit like the
all-time threshold for what we've talked
about with the Bucs that just shows you
let alone the jersey sales the things
he's gonna do from that for that city
everything about it he's gonna make the
whole league on you know put the whole
league on notice this year we're all
gonna be tuned into Tampa so Brady's did
the free agent that had the biggest
impact yeah I mean I agree with you from
the standpoint of total impact they've
they've raised their non club tickets
non club seat tickets by 50% right out
of the gates he's already the hottest
selling jersey and they don't even have
a jersey yet they're literally uniform
yet they lured his numbers gonna be and
the pre-orders are through the roof so
it's a huge impact but from a playing
standpoint a play I would have been torn
I'm glad you won this because DeAndre
Hopkins
the Arizona Cardinals as they're in the
process of putting something together
with Kyler Murray at quarterback who
could explode this year
Kliff Kingsbury explained that to us at
the Scouting Combine four weeks ago I
think the day you were there before you
got whatever it was that puts you on the
the injured well I don't think it was
based upon the symptoms that played out
right in front of me but Kingsbury
talked about how the potential explosion
of calimary could happen this year now
they have DeAndre Hopkins and they kept
Kenyan Drake and Drake wisely signed his
transition tag over the weekend at eight
point four eight million when he sees
one Todd Gurley got in Atlanta
what Melvin Gordon got in Denver I
better sign this eight point four eight
million because that's more than the
market will bear right now those three
guys as the nucleus of that offense I'll
tell you what that they can be on to
something special in Arizona and what a
division that is with the 49ers Seahawks
Rams and the Cardinals with the arrow
pointing up so give me DeAndre Hopkins
Chris yeah I don't disagree with you
Mike I mean on the field he might be the
guy that has the most impact as far as
these new signings that you know you
said it I mean one they're gonna be
cornered into probably having to pay
them big money but to it's a second year
head coach second-year quarterback and
they're gonna make DeAndre Hopkins the
focal point of everything they do
schematically in their passing game to
where you know I would think that
Hopkins is again right up there and
league leader in receptions yards
touchdown everything when it's all said
and done the season so I'm with you
they're not a bad thing alright one last
point hang on what an opportunity for
Hopkins to play with Larry Fitzgerald to
write just to the extent you need any
refinement of your game as you continue
on in your career you get access to
Larry Fitzgerald that's a huge plus form
as well all right go ahead
all right my pick I'm gonna go down I'm
going down to Miami I'm going to Byron
Joe uh you know Byron Jones yes the new
richest cornerback in the history of the
NFL I get it I mean first off Bryan
Flores down there he came from New
England I mean Mike we both know
tremendous pressure on the corners in
New England I mean the defense is based
around the talents of
what the corners can do and how much you
can trust them in our island man Byron
Jones gives Bryan flow there is maybe
the best cornerback duo in all of
football to where they can just say hey
Damien Howard Byron Jones you lock down
the two receivers on the outside and now
I got nine guys in the middle of my
defense to mess with the quarterback and
do a whole bunch of different type of
stuff but ii mean Byron Jones one
healthy mic is in that conversation for
one of the three or four best corners in
football and I think he will really
change the dynamic of that team around
completely and gonna make for his
defense very formidable here going into
the future
yeah I mean think about that when you
put Jones and zaevion Howard out there
against the Josh Allen against the Sam
darn old against whoever the Patriots
put out on the field as a quarterback
that's gonna give the Dolphins a
potential edge and makes them a factor
in the division I still think the bills
are the most likely of the three pay
teams that aren't the Patriots to rise
up but I'm not ready to go to sleep on
the Dolphins because I think Brian
Flores is gonna click with that locker
room pretty quickly all right I'm gonna
go to Indianapolis
the move that I think that you know it's
hard for anyone moved to stand out last
week because there were so many but the
trade of DeForest Buckner which kind of
came out of the clear blue sky
you know the 49ers are trying to figure
out what they were going to do with Arik
Armstead and there was a sense that they
can't keep all four their main defensive
linemen they've paid Deford market value
Nick Bose is gonna have a gigantic
contract eventually between Arik
Armstead and to force Buckner one of
them had to go and I I think they
budgeted what they were gonna pay and
Buckner said no arm said said yes and
they said Buckner go find a trade
partner and he did and the Colts gave up
the 13th overall pick they're paying
Buckner 21 million per year in new money
on his new contract and they see
something there that is gonna give the
Colts possibly their equivalent of
Quentin Nelson on the other side of the
ball a guy who elevates the entire front
seven makes that defense better and it
shows that the culture series after not
spending much in recent years in waiting
for the market to soften in free agency
they're going all in between Buckner on
defense and Phillip
rivers on offense this cults team is not
going to sit back and concede the
division to anyone else no I mean they
should this is what they needed you know
hey was it a little bit rich 21 million
dollars for divorce Buckner yeah it was
a little rich for my money I don't think
he's necessarily an errand Donald there
Brady Jerez class but I think he's still
a really awesome player and I think the
big thing is the Colts need game
changers like we know they got a lot of
good on the roster there's a lot of
depth chris ballard amazing but they
need guys who like hey there's four
minutes left in the fourth quarter and
we're protecting a seven-point lead
we need a defensive lineman who can come
in and get a strip sack fumble or tip
the ball in the air do we get an
interception or whatever it may be
something somebody that can close the
game out on both sides to fall and they
address that with buckler so yeah it's a
little rich for my money but I can
understand it and I give them credit for
making a move that they believed it
alright you're up I'm up and I'm going
Stefon Diggs is Beibei yeah yeah Stefon
Diggs I mean first off we know the trade
yes it was impactful just from from that
standpoint you know your Minnesota
Vikings got a whole boatload of draft
picks you know but also the impact I
think Stefon Diggs is going to have on
the NFL the AFC he says specifically the
Buffalo Bills the Buffalo Bills you know
Josh Allen we saw a great growth last
year we see potential to be a superstar
we did not see one really go-to guy in
that offense or a superstar other than
Josh Allen who can help that offense out
and I think Stefon Diggs gonna have a
huge impact Mike I know you've heard me
say this a lot over the last two weeks
but Diggs is a Swiss Army knife as far
as wide receivers are concerned he can
beat you on the on the outside deep he
can run all those Julian Edelman Wes
Welker type routes in the middle of the
field that Buffalo who runs the New
England offense with Brian Dave wall has
really missed so I just think his impact
not only is a go-to guy but he's gonna
get cold Beasley John Brown that much
more open and more favorable matchups to
where he'll have a huge impact for that
whole football team and especially Josh
Allen and that often here just occurred
to me once upon a time there was a
Seifer who had played for the bills and
ended up with the Vikings named Ahmad
Rashad who did pretty well in his second
act now Stefon Diggs taking the pipeline
in the other direction and I'm excited
to see what he does he's a great player
a great guy we've had him at the Super
Bowl I think the last three years and
there's always been this knit this
nagging sense that something's gonna
happen and it all kind of fell together
last week on the same day the Kirk
Cousins got his extension and I really
do think it's not a coincidence once the
Vikings went all in with cousins for the
next three years that's when Diggs
decided it was time for him to move on
the deal came together quickly
Vikings can't be unhappy with the return
they have an offense that doesn't
necessarily get full value out of his
Stefon Diggs and now we'll see if the
Bills can alright next one for me and if
we talk about impact beyond the field
this one is very impactful this one is
very eventful because with the arrival
of Teddy Bridgewater as the quarterback
of the Carolina Panthers Cam Newton will
be out as the quarterback of the
Panthers and it was no coincidence that
on Wednesday morning the Panthers
announced that Cam Newton had been given
permission to seek a trade because they
knew on Wednesday afternoon it was going
to come out the Teddy Bridgewater was
going to be agreeing to terms it was
actually Tuesday when that all happened
I'm getting my day screwed up from last
week nevertheless Bridgewater Inn after
going five and O last year with the New
Orleans Saints and Newton still on the
roster Chris I just think it's a matter
of time before they end up cutting Cam
Newton because they're gonna have a hell
of a time trading him especially because
you can't get a team's doctors in a
position to actually perform the
physical on the foot the ankle the
shoulder and anything else on cam newton
given the Cova 19 protocols that
prevents a player from going to a team
facility and that prevents the team's
doctors from traveling to go see the
player no yeah I mean you're exactly
right it's a huge impact about the whole
NFL huge impact on Cam Newton's life in
general you know again and this is where
it's still odd to me that all this was
talked about so late in the process most
teams kind of have their plan a and Plan
B at the quarterback position already
figured out by this seventy offseason so
Cam Newton in a really tough spot I
don't know where it goes but you're
right also with the addition of Teddy
Bridgewater him being another and
you starting quarterback in the NFC
south along with Tom Brady to duel
against Matt ride and Drew Brees who
have been mainstays there there's a lot
of cool things there and have great
impact around the NFL I'm interested to
see how this whole Carolina thing shakes
out
Newton's gonna get cut and he's gonna
sign with the Chargers that's my
prediction I'm with you I am with it I
would agree with that I mean where else
could is there doesn't really make sense
and I know you and me both agree like if
I'm the Los Angeles chargers I mean
that's the move to make
I love Tyrod Taylor and do I think they
can win football games with him I do
absolutely but as you and I both have
discussed a lot it's more than about
it's more than that Cam Newton gives
them an identity in that city he is a
true superstar and I think if medically
it checks out I still think Canada's got
a lot of good football to play and I
think it's put in the style of where the
way the Chargers want to play going
forward anyways so to me it would make
sense and I don't really know where else
he would end up other than that all
right
let's let's do a real quick round for
give me give me one more name okay I'm
gonna go with Colin Campbell all right
Baltimore Ravens to a seeker and I kind
of go on under the radar here free
agency but have made some great moves
Colin's Campbell I mean a giant human
being as we know I mean this guy is a
killer but a difference maker a
disrupter Baltimore as we've talked
about so much Mike without a lot of big
guys on their defensive front seven not
a lot of our favorite at the play up
type of talents
Callay of Campbell is not only big which
Baltimore likes but he can cause
disruption and that's where his true
value is to me that was a great move by
the Baltimore Ravens realizing hey we're
in the window we got a quarterback in a
rookie contract let's go for it and get
some better players in here in our front
seven I think alayhis Campbell it
changed the DNA of that defense out or
rounded a big time in a big way look
last one for me is another trade Nick
falls to the Bears look we have seen
foals play extremely well at times he's
going to be reunited with Matt naggy
they had a season together in Kansas
City they actually had a season together
in Philadelphia
in 2012 when on Foles was a rookie and
naggy was there in the final year of the
Andy Reid regime so look
Mitchell drew Biscay clearly on notice
at best he's going to be competing for
the starting job in reality Mike yeah I
think he's got to be the backup I mean
if they make your busy as a sorter the
first time he throws the ball for inches
off targets they're gonna go get Nick
balls in there Drew Pinsky stinks make
Nick Foles the starter go on and then if
he fails then you got your Biscay to
come in and save the day but I think
they're gonna make Falls earn it I don't
think they're gonna hand it to him I
think they don't right it's risky a
chance in training camp whether under
what extent there even is a tree that's
a different issue altogether he gets a
chance but I think it would be false all
right we're gonna take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports